miss me in two yeah
it's a good one
toasted guava what's up dude
okay hero mk 22
playing
what is this the nimzo larsen
that's what this is
okay
well let's play in the center
let's play in this in the center
you deserve a follow awesome thank you
dude
i really appreciate that
hell yeah yeah by the way also if you're
enjoying the stream
agory
my man if you're enjoying the stream
definitely be sure to follow my personal
twitch channel too
which is twitch.tv arcg3
which agory just put the link in the
chat
sweet
sweet sweet sweet
okay
i don't know if that is a really great
move because we just have this move
we defend d6 and we're attacking the
knight and we have a great center
so
this looks good to me so far this bishop
is shut down that's why we've played f6
early
i know this 20-something guy who never
ever went to school wasn't really
homeschooled parents let him be and he
is way smarter than most who did
yeah i think school is really
oops
let's not hang a pawn here
let's not hang a pawn
uh i think
uh
doing school
is certainly
it certainly helps your intelligence
but it is not the only thing
it's not the only determiner of your
intelligence
okay
um
well
let's play this move
i like this move
yeah
what's up
arcg3 seems like he streams constantly
i basically i'm basically live 24 7.
yeah i haven't really streamed a lot on
my personal channel recently
the main reason is because i've been
uploading youtube videos
let's take
and
[Music]
we'll take
oh i should have god
oh my goodness
could i have saved that anyway
we're still up a piece
that's not bad
do i actually want to take with the rook
yeah i can i can take the i'm not
hanging upon because we would get
checkmate
open files are too powerful
too powerful
why is it 2058 using none of their time
don't know man
i don't know
oh no my pawn oh no dude
oh no my pawn again
part two
electric boogaloo
very busy
i'm very busy here guys
takes
oh no my queen oh no dude
oh no my queen
oh it's just it's terrible oh my
goodness
all right
i think the most recent one was talking
about how we don't exist
i think you're right
that video actually did
very badly
in terms of analytics
it did
very very badly
okay i see a very nice outpost for our
extra minor piece
we're going to play oh okay well
let's start with king e7
and if he gets the michael dublay then
okay
let's challenge
challenge
and we might have some ideas of getting
the horsey fork here
queen trade with style
oh no my pawn
damn
okay
that's okay
totally kulioski
still up a pony and a pawn
at least i was in the video
you were in the video
yeah
the same there's chess club channel
um
also on the ark g3 channel the rg3
youtube channel
but
most recently has been on the saint
louis chess club channel
we've got some more st louis chess club
videos going live
um the next one will
probably go live on saturday
on the sailors chess club channel
so a ways away but i'm thinking about i
think i'll upload something to the arcg3
channel tomorrow
i think i will
okay
just chilling out here
if you play rook d3 and trade everything
do you think the end game is winning it
is
but
i don't want to make things
like being up one pawn um
could still be
somewhat tricky potentially
being up two pawns of course
would
be winning in most lines
but okay now i just want to
play king f4
and now we are threatening to play rook
d3
okay
and now it's actually very tricky
because um
we're gonna get rook d3 anyway
pick up the juice
picking up the juice here he does not
have any past pawns
so we are
we're just gravy here we are gravy
good game hero mk22
we've got devretsky on our side
i put your name on screen oh you're
right
i put
i think i put your name also liberated
toaster's name
you guys are now famous
officially
be prepared for the paparazzi
can we put more names on screen
well since that video happened i have
now made it so that everyone
everyone's name appears on screen
whenever they send anything in chat
so
that is that is the deal
time to make toasters the most popular
kitchen device
what
everyone's asking for my autograph so
annoying tbh
so annoying
all right let's berserk
are we are we gonna win this arena or
are we not
okay
i think it's time to get sweaty here
we're really gonna win this arena we
gotta act like it
we're gonna act like we're gonna win
this arena
that
i'm pretty sure is a blunder
knight b3
want to play this move
big gusta what's up man
title talking about history and school
classic
just won a poker tourney big gustago
is this a fork
no
um maybe it is
it's a free pawn
take six takes
bishop takes
check
let's castle
and
now i think this is a free pawn
yep let's go for it
he actually has bishop takes f2 in the
end so maybe it's not super free
okay now we have a choice we have this
move or this move
um
all
right let's go for this one
this looks good to me guys i don't know
about you but
um
looks pretty good to me
like we've got two
pretty big threats
oh guys oh my god look at this guys
takes here
check
if he goes there we win the queen or
sorry it's mate so he has to go here
bishop g7 check
and then uh he has to take we win the
queen oh
ooh
this is
this is a ko i've ever seen one
this is clinical
do i take that or
um
or what
oh i
i don't think i do
or do i
yeah sure
we're gonna be up the exchange
well i didn't think that was the correct
move
all right
let's just be up the exchange
up the exchange and the pawn
hitting uh in two spots there
all right
let's hit the bishop
get the skewer action
this move
probably doesn't work
get over here mike tyson
because this is a ko that's why we play
the e-rook not the a-rook
so the a-pawn is defended
now that's a pretty good move
that is actually an incredibly good move
dang dude
what a move
all right well let's uh let's get the
trades yo
and now i need some speed
give me some speed
up a full pony
okay
active king everybody active king
i think that's gonna be it
for a buddy here
got to be careful here but um
the
technique will be clinical
uh i'm gonna show off some clinical end
game technique here
and we'll make a make a queen here
very nice
check
uh
not gonna get me today buddy
not getting me today
no thank you
all right
jm paul
good game to you my friend
very good game
let's go
easy clap
big gusta you said you won a poker
tournament
which poker tournament did you win
get him out of here
and with the berserk and with the
berserk
that was a great piece sacrifice
what did you say
oh dang
fantastic piece sacrifice okay do we
berserk here
this guy's the leader so i'm kind of
nervous about berserking
but we're gonna try to play fast
yeah queen e5 looked pretty good
got the london
the low mega lull london
uh what do i do let's bring the queen
here
let's get the queen developed
yep
didn't on passant he did not
we've got some
weird bononi structure that
white i don't think
i think white should go e4 and f4 but
they don't go for that
this is a nice move
oh no my bishop oh no
okay
sure let's drop it all the way back
now
keep developing this
i don't know what his plan is with this
bishop
don't quite know what you're planning
there buddy
okay
let's re-maneuver the queen
have some ideas of getting this knight
to f4 later
you can tell he knew what to do like
he's got good opening principles
i think he's stuck in the middle game
now
off for the queen trade
i think he could go for it
pre-move king d8
manca s
good night agori thank you
thank you for sticking around
i appreciate you
i remember playing a couple games it
went d4 at f6 d5
yeah that's kind of weird
that is kind of weird
darsh it up
2012 what's up dude
five card draw attorney for 120 dollars
not bad
not bad was it a sit and go
sit and go tournament or like a big
tournament
yeah if queen takes it would have been
illegal okay so he wants to do fancy
knight c7
um
but like come on bro you think you're
going to get me with knight c7
i'll just castle and what you got to
move back you're losing a pawn he
actually loses a pawn here
um otherwise i'll play a6
and then you have to move back
so yeah knight b5 tricky move but not a
very good move
because i think now i just
just get this juice
takes
d4 knight f6 d5 the anti-grunfeld
i think there are probably some better
ways to avoid the grunfeld
[Laughter]
meme
okay we're up a pawn
up upon
definitely
looking pog here
sure we'll take
and go bishop g5
f5
expansion
and now we can play bishop f6 we're not
blocking our f
pawn i don't know exactly what we're
doing with these but we're gonna just
gonna do something important later in
the game probably
work ae8
just like your opening principles i mean
you don't know exactly what you're going
to do when you put your pawn on e4 or
when you put your pawn on d4 in the
first move you don't know exactly what
the pawn is going to do but it's going
to do something useful
you know that
let's play e4 to stop f3 and then we'll
play oh
okay now do we on facant
is on facant forced
time to
attack this pony here
we actually we could have played bishop
e3 check
hit the pony
and
what i'm going to check
too bad we're not actually winning any
material there
i thought we were but we are not
she plays this move though we'll win
some material
we'll win the king
but
i think
like it's pretty obvious to see rook g6
even if you don't see rookie one you see
king h7 so
um
probably probably will play rook to f3
unless
unless he doesn't see rook f3 rookie one
rook f1
in which case
he might play something else
like he might play that he might play
that move
uh yeah i mean rook f3 and i i don't
think white was losing any material
there
gg
gg okay
the number two guy
i don't think we berserk do we berserk
all right
screw it
we're berserking
good luck
okay
not off to a good start
that's a good move to see though i'm
happy to see that
so we've got some threats here
um
play f5
pin this guy
pin this guy
oh guys this is this is looking rough
oh but oh guys we're
we're down a pawn
oh my goodness guys i totally forgot
we're down upon never mind we're totally
losing
totally losing this game
well
i thought this move looks pretty good
bishop f2 looks lights out i think
probably what you meant was um
in this position bishop f7 which i
didn't think worked i did not think that
move uh
worked
we could take
let's take
the classic uh double bishop sacrifice
check
now we go here
you can defend once like this
um oh just take it
oh but we're down a piece oh guys never
mind we're down a piece
totally we're losing guys i forgot
because material is everything isn't it
okay
now you have to sack the queen
to stop checkmate
and then we're probably going to do this
and this
takes checking mate
bbd good game to you
look who's in first
look who's in first
last time i joked around i blundered
backrank mate
maybe one of the times i joked around
not the last time i joked around though
not the last time i
i joke around a lot
there's
i think there's a million clips of me uh
messing around and then blundering
okay
we're berserking
get the berserk up in here
i'm the only title player in the turning
no i'm not
there's literally a fide master playing
what the heck is that
i'm playing knight g8
all right well
i already know what i'm gonna do
what's this guy doing guys
i mean this is
this is not what i would consider good
chess
i know how i want to punish this french
it's frenchman
which square
let's drop it all the way back
this may be too much
maybe h4 was not super great maybe i
want my knight on h4 okay now this is
fantastic
now this is fantastic
i don't know
what the heck this guy's doing
here's this move now oh i missed that
move
okay he missed it too
well maybe now he's gonna play it
i'm threatening to sack
what the heck is this guy doing
he's got some weird move moves bro
okay
let's open things up here
oh i got skewered
or did i
it's all part of my plan
wow
um
oh no
play f4
and
i don't know what we're gonna do next
we're gonna try to not lose
fm stands for fake master
yeah fm is a fake title
sorry if you're an fm i hate to break it
to you
most fm's don't even know that most fm's
don't even know that
fm is not a real title
we've got great pieces though like he
can't do anything
can't really do anything here
just great for us
i think i want what do i want to do i
want to get this g-pawn rolling but
um
but if i move my knight then he has
knight f5
oh
well you're making me very happy dude
you're making me very happy
i don't know what you're doing with your
bishop
i don't know what you're doing with your
bishop there
okay
we're gonna pick up pawn
numero
trace
he's a he has a good move here though i
missed
that was not the move that i was
thinking he should play
okay he had this move there i miss i
missed it again okay the bishop takes f4
deflection
um
okay we want to play g4
we've still got all eight pawns
all eight pawn it's all eight of them
okay i didn't like uh i didn't like g4
97 so we'll start with queen h3
this looks pretty good
when will i show off my skills on the
london system
right because lm stands for london
master
exactly i i totally forgot
totally forgot guys
this queen is sleeping i mean the queen
is pressuring this b2 spot which is
making me i mean make it hard for money
to develop his bishop which is making me
hard for
you know what i'm trying to say make it
hard for me to develop this rook
um
um
oh geez my time oh my goodness i totally
forgot okay set up some discoveries also
over to defend g5 f5 i was worried about
rook takes g5 this pawn hangs maybe
there's some
nasties over here
um
that's a pretty darn good move is it
is it a good move
okay maybe it's not a super great move
these pawns are rolling
these pawns are rolling
tough position here
gotta get some speed
tricky tricky tricky for him here he's
got two hanging things
hmm
ah
dang it
dang it
that was rough
that was a rough one
we're never actually
a lot better
we're
a tiny bit better
get a lot of uh a lot of good plays
bishop c3 i miss bishop c3
yeah we're uh we have to play rook d1
queen takes d4 killed me
hey that's okay
that's okay
well that means that only means we come
back stronger
come back stronger
we all know that it is lost master so
let's yeah it's obviously a loss master
come on guys
just look at how many games i'm losing
tonight
yeah a tough game for 10 minutes
definitely tough
all right let's get another game get
another game eh
all right akarsh
good luck
you know what berserk
some people think berserk is um
it's a disadvantage but
see it's actually a huge advantage
because
when you berserk
you're actually mentally defeating your
opponent
like
when you when a titled player berserks
against you
you're just you know it's all over
before the game even has even started
um
so
even though it might be an objective
disadvantage
it's just
it's all about
mentally defeating your opponent
and that's all that matters
check
this is some nice
vienna gambit theory
now that move
i think that's a good move
bishop a6 let's stop the castle
hit the pony
what's up
okay
maybe we should have castle queenside
there
yeah
it's castle queenside stop the queenside
castle now
what up what up
that move
it's not a bad move now because now he
can castle there's no problem
he didn't castle
he's playing really well here
takes
yep
yeah it should be good for us
we've got the connected pass pawn
opposite colored bishops um
we protect this guy
oh shoot
i totally forgot about that move
let's get the king up in here
the king up in this business
c5
rook d8
oh no my pawn
he's barely holding things together here
barely we've got a very active king
oh that's a free dude
that's a free dude
that's what i like to call a free pope
a free popsicle
free popsicle mentally defeated guys
he's mentally defeated
akarsh good game to you my friend
good game to you
poseidon
you know it my man
good
luck got a nice spanish game here
well i think i think white certainly
messed up
his plans here
he's not going to get knight f5 in
as much as he would like to he's not
going to get it
he wasn't really paying attention to
what i was doing
that's the problem
mainline spanish d3 yep
d3 definitely some anti-marshall
no
i don't like that
uh we'll drop it back
drop it back with this guy
might have to be careful about f7
in these lines
this is actually a very
shaky position
like it's extremely shaky here
okay but he resolves everything
so
this is like
super chill now
let's not hang a piece
let's not hang a piece there
hey
gotta be careful
gotta be careful here
eh
uh
okay my bishop is opened up now which is
very nice
i want to break down this diagonal if i
can
i think we've got a good position
this night or is this night hopping
bad move
do i actually know martial theory
gotta be honest
not really
something i need to learn
what am i doing here
um
that is pretty funny hilarious
welcome welcome back
um
i
i'm currently trying to win this game
this guy's playing
very well
check
i guess we'll take with a pawn
not looking super great
it could could have been worse though
could have been worse
check
wow
i'm surprised at that move
okay well
i guess it wasn't as bad as i thought it
was
check
takes
[Music]
that one hurts
that one hurts
poseidon my man
oh ouch
let's go
thanks to this channel today i use the
turn of
the turn of phrase
pog horsey forks in a conversation
was it about chess though was it about
chess
we're playing capnobin
i think
i remember this was a king's gambit game
no
oh i remember i remember the game we
played versus cap no bing
um
we got a scotch gambit double berserk
here obviously
obviously a double berserk
got a nice scotch gambit main line
here bishop e3
i don't know if bishop e3 is actually
mainline
but okay we've transposed back into
mainline
stuff know f5 is a move here
so let's go for it
i know it's not
i don't think it's supposed to be
the best move but i know it is a move
queen e7
rook b8
and i mean we're nice and we're groovy
here we're nice and groovy
shattered his pawns over here
he's got the connected pass pawn but
we're holding it down for now holding
down the fort
and
let's take play rook b2
if he takes with the queen
of course
i think we're doubling up here
so you see moving the knight or
defending it
he defends
get the michael duble up in here
hit this guy again
just
why not
now
check
are we winning a pawn
maybe i shouldn't take that pawn
i'll go here instead
work d1
ideas of rook d3
and now
now if we trade now i'm okay with taking
this pawn
okay
c5
this pawn is pinned
he has very sus king safety in this
position
um we're just kicking this knight
and we're also conveniently defending b8
we're going to pick up another pawn here
this should
hopefully be a win
hopefully it'll be a win
prediction or if there are any mods here
you can set up a prediction for the next
game
try to keep everything defended
we're gonna make the two connected pass
pawns
no problem i mean i don't think i'm too
scared of that check
oh no
oh no
forgot the battery
forgot about the battery cap no bing
oh geez
gotta try to find some king safety here
check
he doesn't really have any checks
we'll force the queen trade and that
should be good enough
looking like a w
this would also force the queen trade
takes
i have to go h6 oh
okay well this should just be
easily winning at this point
cap no bing good game to you
all right
25 with fire
with fire
i'll set up a prediction
okay
what
i
i typed in will harrison win the
tournament
and
it says this name like this question is
not compliant with our guidelines
what the heck
okay
that's weird that was weird but that's
okay there we go good luck everybody
make your predictions
keflino
good luck
let's get some moves in yo
wild man a wilder
he's going wild oh my goodness
that is
you were just
asking to be roasted
you were asking for it here my dude
look at your jeep on
if that is not
a juicer
that needs to be exploited then i don't
know what is
oh
this is uh this is getting heavy
getting heavy
we might see this line
97 takes takes 95
rook g6 virginia queen g5
and then he has to move the knight
i think i'm getting the pawn which looks
pretty good
will i win this is not just this game
this is the entire tournament
current leader
is 32 with fire
we're 25 with fire
rigged
maybe maybe it's rigged
maybe the
current tournament leader
cares a lot about his st louis channel
some of his chess club channel points
what the heck
okay
takes or out check
not takes
check
takes
oh no dude oh no
i'm losing a piece because my bishop's
pinned to my queen
oh no
check
be careful
um
that might be a good move
but okay um
this should this still this should still
be
very good for us
got to protect c2 here in case he plays
b4 but this knight's coming to d6
and um
yeah let's castle
starting to win a pawn here
uh well no he hits the g pawn in the end
so i don't think i am
i could have played bishop e4 though
that would have been good
maybe castling was slightly inaccurate
maybe i should have played rook d1
i think that's probably what i should
have done
okay well now my knight gets in
very
very pog champ
i want to play bishop e4
hit the knight
check
oh i think i'm just winning a piece here
yeah
not bad
not bad at all
now this knight is pretty good here but
it's also blocking my rook so i think
we'll drop it back to e4
double up
and just
we either we'll either trade everything
and then win the end game or we'll just
checkmate with the rooks
in the night
fork them
pog
forks or pog
oh we could have we could have uh could
have won the rook
i missed it
that is uh
that's okay
check
check again
okay are you just giving up at this
point
takes
we'll get the king in here
and
well now we're winning this pawn
not too bad
there's
absolutely no way that black can
make a pass pawn here
is the only way would be with like some
pre-move trick
but i don't think that's gonna happen
good game keflino
okay
how's this guy doing
even material
so far this guy's game he didn't berserk
though he did not preserve he has been
berserking
oh no he hasn't been berserking he
hasn't berserked at all
uh he's been playing
really well though
he's won every game
now he he's briefly up a piece but that
was because it was a trade
okay
all right i think
probably don't berserk this game
probably
mathematically good to not berserk
let's try to play quickly
castles
rookie 8
b6
maybe we'll get the fettuccine up in
here
the fettuccine
that's what i like to that's what we
like to hear
e6 try to break it down
um
hmm
probably should take this guy
yeah
there was maybe knight takes g3 but i
didn't want him to get like super tricky
with some like bishop h6 move
hmm
to revive this knight to f6
that is where it will be best
the great defender of the king
is that italian
i don't know is it italian
i don't know
let's uh induce the weakness here
no problemo
takes
should be happy trading because of all
these pawns
like
dude this is a he just gave me a winning
endgame here
offer a draw this is winning for me bro
keep your pawns locked on the light
squares
maybe this was not a super good plan
okay let's drop it back
ah dang did i uh
i think i messed this up
thank goodness
that's frustrating
i'm i feel insulted by his draw offer
though i feel insulted
it's just not
a drawn position at all
and being down on time
like dang bro
okay
we have to try to go for
something like this right
the widening of the beachhead
is that what dovretsky called it
god dang it
well that was super frustrating
i have to play f4
f4 dude f4
and then g4
just makes a lot of sense
this would have been sort of would have
been the best f4 because i have to stop
him from playing f4 ah
so obvious
okay
now it's gonna be close
now it's gonna be close
a caf team what's up dude hi i have a
favor
what's your favor
okay well
do we i think we have to berserk we have
to berserk this
even though this guy is
this guy's good
this guy is a good
strong chess player
but if we don't berserk then we won't
have any chance of winning
can i play fast
and accurately
move scares me
check
where's your king going buddy
where is your king going
that's what i thought
okay i don't think this is super bad
though because there takes takes and
knight e4
um
you're really going after that pawn
well i don't
i think it's probably not
not super great but
uh you can do you bow
buddy
you can do you
now that's the move i was waiting for
because now i can play knight e4
and if you play king e1 then i can play
knight b4
right
he didn't go for that though
it's unfortunate
um
sure let's pick up the bishop here
pick it up
play f6 to restrict the knight
oh we lost a pawn
oh dang
um
[Music]
okay
accidentally hung up on there
but we've got the bishop pair
and that is all that matters
maybe we could have played e5 bishop e6
maybe that would have been better
actually
well i think this is a fork now
we're winning back our pawn
unless he wants to play bishop b1 in
which case i'd be very happy if he
wanted to do that
right
take
and we have even material once again
guys it's gonna be really hard to win at
this point because
first place is eight points ahead of us
even if we win this game there's still
five points ahead of us and they're
probably in another game right now
um
okay let's double the pawns
perfect
oh it's benny thompson
uh man what do i play here
spendy thank you for the raid my man
i hope you had a great stream
guys if you don't know spenny what are
you doing
is the number one up and coming chest
streamer
okay
are we just gonna get a draw here
we're going to try not to draw this
it's going to be hard
yo nosy compass what's up man
check
this is
i don't think we're
playing this very well right now
this this is maybe not super great for
us
uh
i'm trying to think
do we sack this pawn
okay so we'll start by taking
because now we have here
and there
should be a draw
or i mean mainly it's just
these guys are doubled i might actually
be able to come back around over here
like this eh
it could be very
good potentially
potentially very good
that's a good move though
because now he
cuts my king
oh my time oh no my time
that was potentially a very bad move
i think we're okay
i think we're okay
uh that's a weird move because before
now you had the deflection tactic but
not anymore
but
still most likely drawn
well i just realized this is on a dark
square
so let's attack that
we should not have done that
should not have done that
we needed to keep this weakness
now it's
just too easy
for him
all right another draw
come on
yo hi i'm an organizer of teams named
acaf what's up dude
i'll take that pawn
this guy i don't i don't think you're
gonna flag me
i don't think he's gonna be able to flag
me
but uh
i'll see you try
come on come on guys
how's it going
it's potentially the most boring chest
stream
out of any chest stream on twitch right
now
how long have we been doing this
definitely the most boring chess stream
in all of twitch right now
definitely the most
boring jet stream
probably on all of twitch
[Laughter]
what's up guys what's up what's up
dang
oops oops how did that happen
how did that happen
who is flagging who there
who flag to
only had less than 20 seconds for 50
moves i wasn't even worried
wasn't even worried the whole time
okay
well if we want this game to count for
the tournament we got a berserk
draw 29 good luck
oh no
come on we need something uh we need
something that we can win quickly we
can't beat the pierce quickly i've never
beaten the pierce quickly in my life
oh did i just hang a pawn
oh dang
takes
what the heck is this guy doing
that cannot be a good move
that cannot be good
oops
oh dang
i lost back my pawn
i didn't mean to do that
well
at least we've got
he's got an isolated pawn and we've got
the open file
this is just this is very pog
it's very pogs
pog my guy
my guys
pile up here
try to win this pawn
what is this guy doing
uh
we'll take
oh
oh it's a fork
oh you didn't think you'd get forked did
you
knight d5 the horsey fork
it's a horsey fork
how are you doing
yeah you gotta be careful
gotta be careful
all right if we can win this in the next
two minutes
uh we will
this will account for the tournament
so come on come on resign we gotta be
magnus carlson resign
resign resign redesign
all right a calf a caf team hey i
appreciate you coming in here but um
don't advertise
don't just come in here and advertise
right
that's not nobody likes that nobody
likes that
um
it's actually a good move
okay well we'll play the rook end game
we're up a pawn
slowly grind it down this king safety is
just
he's never going to be up be able to
activate his rooks with this king
um and this rook
just shut down the f file
and uh we're picking up
a bunch of pawns here
resign freeze on
come on
please
not gonna get it
not gonna get the resignation
dang it
well
that's it for the tournament i guess
no
the the doubters
doubters win i guess
we got second place
we're up a bunch of pawns yo
rip like 59 pawns
okay now how do you win a game when
you're up a bunch of pawns like this the
first step is to cut off the king which
we've done
the second step
is to promote a pawn
which
is what we're going to do
now
we're not going to take this pawn
because then his king gets out we're
just going to play king h5 and just
slowly do
this is what i like to call the stepa
it's when you step
up your pawn
that's why it's called the stepa
g6 kingh6 kingh7
so now we're threading checkmate
you have to be very careful here that
you don't
accidentally stalemate your opponent
because for example if i play g7 here
then
there might be like rook c6
maybe probably not
but you have to be careful that's the
point the mad rook
tactic right
uh
how should we continue here
check
here takes
there
it's good
or just takes
there and there we could promote either
pawn i guess i think g7 wins
i think b6 wins
yeah let's play b6
it's a little bit less risky i think
because we keep our king safe
and now we're going to do this and this
and this
why didn't he push the b yeah there's a
million ways you can win here
the reason i didn't go
um
i guess never mind
never mind
all right we're good we finally get the
resignation
[Music]
dang it
if we had
if we had won the game that we drew we
had won this game
which i think that it's very possible we
win if we play f4 here
then we would have tied we would have
tied first place
but i mean what can you do we had a
great performance
great performance
great uh great tournament
win for me yeah win for
me too
if you're watching on youtube hey thanks
for watching
and
like the video be sure to check out my
personal youtube channel which is twitch
or not twitch but youtube.com
c
arcg3
i'll put it in the description and if
you're on twitch you can click it right
there
um yeah thank you very much
have a great rest of your day goodbye
goodbye
goodbye